tehran hauptstadt des ira das leben ist
zurück auf den straßen der
millionenmetropole
dabei ist teheran nach wie vor das
zentrum der korona pandemie im land ein
land das nicht nur gegen ein virus
kämpft sondern seit gründung der
islamischen republik vor über 40 jahren
auch gegen mächtige politische feinde
angeführt von den usa die ganze welt
weiß dass wir nicht unter normalen
bedingungen leben können
wir befinden uns unter dem druck von
sanktionen und obwohl wir mit sanktionen
belegt sind sind wir in der lage ihnen
zu widerstehen und unser land so gut es
geht zu führen
gerade mal sechs wochen vielleicht
galten strenge schutzmaßnahmen gegen die
ausbreitung des corona virus dann begann
die regierung als eines der ersten
länder weltweit diese beschränkungen
bereits wieder aufzuheben
die lage sei unter kontrolle man wolle
so verkündet es die staatspropaganda
vorsichtig und den kleinen schritten
wieder zur normalität zurückkehren
war e2v beliefert supermärkte mit waren
in diesem laden wird er immerhin ein
paar datteln los sonst läuft das
geschäft schlecht dass die krise bald
überstanden sein könnte glaubt er nicht
viele läden sind noch geschlossen wie
fast food läden und restaurants
aber die geschäfte die wieder in betrieb
sind finden kaum kunden denn die leute
haben einfach angst
viele glauben dass die zahlen viel höher
liegen
aber naja wir nehmen es hin wie sie es
behaupten
mir ist es wichtig dass meine familie
nicht auf die straße geht
ich muss arbeiten ich muss eben raus
aber meine familie bleibt zu hause
neben mussawi ist studentin arbeitet
nebenher im laden als kassiererin
die regierung will uns in sicherheit
wiegen und spielt die gefahr runter sagt
sie für mich sind die statistiken nicht
glaubwürdig ich denke die regierung sagt
uns nicht die wahrheit und was man in
den sozialen netzwerken findet scheint
dagegen übertrieben zu sein
keinem kann man vertrauen die regierung
kommt mit niedrigen zahlen damit die
leute weniger angst haben und um die
eigene inkompetenz zu kaschieren
rückblick schon anfang februar soll es
die ersten infektionen im land geben
doch noch unternimmt die regierung
nichts offenbar will man die
parlamentswahlen am 21 februar nicht
gefährden hofft auf eine hohe
wahlbeteiligung doch der plan müsse
die religiösen hardliner setzten sich
durch verhindert beschränkungen der
pilgerreisen und schließung der moschee
die gläubigen besuchen weiter
ungehindert die heiligen stätten der
schiiten
sie tragen das virus ins land bald
gehört iran zu den von der pandemie am
härtesten getroffenen länder auf einer
pressekonferenz ende februar zeigt sich
vize-gesundheitsminister hariri
schwitzend und hustend und muss tags
darauf eingestehen dass auch er mit dem
virus infiziert seien
ich werde meine aufgaben per telefon aus
dem krankenhaus erledigen aber in ein
paar tagen wird es mir sicher besser
gehen dann kehre ich zurück um euch
wieder zu dienen bis bald auf
wiedersehen erst über einen monat nach
ausbruch der cholera epidemie also erst
mitte märz werden die moscheen
geschlossen
auch die heiligen schreine in maschad
und kommt dort versammelt sich eine
wütende menge vor dem geschlossenen
schreien und protestiert versucht das
gebäude zu stürmen viele halten das
corona virus immer noch für eine lüge
sind überzeugt dass nur er glaube und
das gemeinsame gebet sie vor einer
infektion schützt jetzt erst werden
viele geschäfte und betriebe geschlossen
die leute sollen zu hause bleiben und
abstand halten trotzdem verhindert ist
die regierung nicht dass sich zum
iranischen neujahrsfest am 21 märz
millionen auf den weg machen in den
urlaub zum traditionellen familienbesuch
diese inkonsequenz wird fatale folgen
haben
statt reiseverbot durchhalteparolen des
obersten religionsführers wenn wir es
schaffen unsere eigene produktion zu
steigern und zu entwickeln können wir
unsere wirtschaftsprobleme beendet und
die sanktionen die man gegen uns
verhängt hat werden sich sogar zu
unserem nutzen wenn die betriebe
beginnen masken zu nehmen und
medizinprodukte selbst herzustellen
die regierung beantragt einen kredit
beim internationalen währungsfonds um
die wirtschaft zu stützen forderte die
usa auf die wirtschaftssanktionen
aufzuheben washington aber lehnt ab mit
der begründung irans führung unterstütze
weiter schiitische terrorgruppen im
mittleren osten
es wäre eine gute gelegenheit für die
usa gewesen sich für ihr falsches
verhalten zu entschuldigen
es ging um ein humanitäres problem
und niemand hätte sie dafür kritisiert
hätten sie die historische gelegenheit
genutzt und den falschen weg verlassen
und hätten die sanktionen aufgehoben
in der iranischen nation zu sagen seht
her wir haben nichts gegen das iranische
volk
die usa bieten an medizinische hilfe zu
leisten
dieses angebot lehnt wiederum die
iranische seite ab johanni präsentiert
stattdessen medienwirksam im land
hergestellte medizinprodukte und
verhöhnt die zustände in den
krankenhäusern des westrings der
politische kampf mit den usa jedoch
während der chor wonach diese wald irans
revolutionsgarden präsentieren gar eine
eigene angeblich bahnbrechende erfindung
einen viren detector der sei in der lage
so erklärt der kommandeur viren in einem
umkreis von 100 metern mit 80
prozentiger genauigkeit aufzuspüren nun
so die botschaft kämpfen also auch irans
elite kräfte an vorderster front gegen
das corona leitet die biologischen
fakultät an der teheraner universität
ja sagt er anfangs habe es fehler im
kampf gegen korona gegeben und die lage
war dramatisch aber es sei mal wieder
gelungen den kopf aus der schlinge zu
ziehen
wegen der sanktionen haben wir uns
leider nicht viele moderne medikamente
beschaffen können
und wenn es mal möglich war dann nur mit
großen schwierigkeiten mit großer
verspätung und zu einem sehr hohen preis
es gab deshalb einen mangel an neuen
medikamenten und technologien und das
hat er natürlich negative folgen für
unsere bürger andererseits haben uns die
sanktionen dazu gezwungen uns
unabhängiger zu machen und die
eigenproduktion wichtiger güter
auszubauen
heute decken wir bis zu 97 prozent
unseres medikamenten bedarf selbst wir
haben die erlaubnis bekommen das
nationale influenza forschungszentrum zu
besuchen
am 24 februar hätten sie hier den ersten
positiven corona test gehabt das aber
bedeutet dass das virus schon lange
vorher inland war meint leiterin dr
zwar warnen die wissenschaftler davor
die korona maßnahmen zu schnell zu
lockern
sie bestätigen aber die linie der
regierung sagen man habe das schlimmste
überstanden
ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass wir
den höhepunkt hinter uns haben
ab jetzt können wir eine abfallende
kurve erwarten es kann sein dass wir an
einzelnen tagen wieder etwas steigen die
zahlen sehen aber im großen und ganzen
scheint die zahl der neuinfektionen
abzunehmen zeitweise müssen die
iranischen tageszeitungen den betrieb
einstellen angeblich um infektionen zu
vermeiden
das regime versucht die öffentliche
meinung zu kontrollieren die aber ist
trotz der guten nachrichten schlecht ich
denke nicht dass unsere führung die
krise gut bewältigt hat ich denke sie
hätten von vornherein eine landesweite
quarantäne verhängen sollen doch eine
komplette ausgangssperre hat es bis
heute in iran nie gegeben im gegenteil
bereits mitte april werden erste
beschränkungen wieder aufgehoben
geschäfte mit niedrigem infektionsrisiko
dürfen wieder öffnen
zuerst in den provinzen
wir wollen uns die lage außerhalb
teherans ansehen unser team macht sich
auf den weg von der hauptstadt in die
nachbarprovinz masandaran um teheran zu
verlassen und die provinz grenze zu
überqueren brauchen wir eine
sondergenehmigung des zuständigen
ministeriums an der stadtgrenze der
erste kontrollpunkt wir dürfen
weiterfahren
in den kleinen orten außerhalb teherans
sehen wir am straßenrand nur
geschlossene geschäfte und gaststätten
auch der laden von ali kur ist seit
wochen zu man hört so viele
unterschiedliche sachen wir leben hier
weit weg von der stadt und kriegen nicht
alles mit ich schaue fernsehen und lese
viel im internet die einen sagen sie
hätten alles unter kontrolle
die anderen sagen alles sei viel
schlimmer geworden genaue zahlen
bekommen wir nicht
200 kilometer sind es von teheran bis
ans kaspische meer richtung norden durch
das malerische elbers gebirge
auf halber strecke erreichen wir die
grenze zur provinz masandaran hier
kontrolliert die polizei
mitarbeiter des roten halbmonds machen
gesundheitschecks auch hier kommen wir
nur mit unserer sondergenehmigung durch
wir überprüfen die personalausweise um
zu sehen ob die personen aus unserer
provinz stammen oder nicht sind sie in
masandaran gemeldet dürfen sie weiter
fahren sonst müssen sie umdrehen
die situationen masandaran ist
verheerend weil die straßen nicht früher
gesperrt wurden
viel zu viele sind aus teheran hierher
gekommen es gab hier kaum infektionen
aber heute gehören wir zu den zwei
risikoreichsten provinzen nur noch
teheran hat mehr infektionen es waren
die gäste aus der hauptstadt die ende
märz das virus in die küstenprovinz
brachten ankunft in lohsa die küste lebt
vom tourismus
heute haben die einheimischen den strand
für sich
alina rose lässt seine kinder nur noch
ganz selten aus dem haus schulen und
kindergärten sind seit vielen wochen
geschlossen
den kindern fällt zu hause die decke auf
den kopf sagt er
doch die zuversicht die seine regierung
verbreitet teilt er nicht
alina rose ist weiter misstrauisch wie
so viele gemieden
[Musik]
zu uns nach hause darf niemand mehr zu
besuch kommen meine frau will das nicht
und passt sehr genau auf denn wir haben
noch ein anderes kind das ist noch sehr
klein
wir gehen kaum noch aus der wohnung und
akzeptieren keinen besuch und ich denke
das machen den moment fast alle so ali
ist bauingenieur leitet einen trupp auf
einer der ganz wenigen baustellen auf
denen überhaupt noch gearbeitet wird
erst die wirtschaftssanktionen der usa
jetzt die korona krise seit zwei jahren
gebe es nur bergab sagt an
ja unter den sanktionen zu leben das war
schon schwer genug aber jetzt kommt noch
corona als krönung obendrauf
die arbeitssituation ist wegen corona
gerade sehr schlecht viele bauprojekte
wurden gestoppt
ein teil unserer afghanischen
arbeitskräfte hat das land verlassen
wegen der seuche und wegen des
wertverlustes unserer währung so sieht
es im moment aus gera suhl arbeitet
schon seit langem für ali
der afghane hat noch seinen job viele
seiner landsleute nicht mehr so lange
ich atme werde hier bleiben sagte
alleine hier in der gegend waren wir so
80 bis 100 afghanische arbeiter heute
sind wir gerade noch 20 und freunde
erzählen mir aus anderen gegenden das
gleiche seit afghanische arbeiter aus
iran in die heimat zurückkehren steigen
dort die zahlen der korona infektion
in lohsa haben viele geschäfte nun
wieder geöffnet auch der baustoffhandel
bei dem alii einkauft arbeitet wieder
doch an ihr der ladenbesitzer kann sich
darüber nicht so recht freuen
wegen corona hatten wir eineinhalb
monate lang zu jetzt haben wir zwar
wieder auf aber aus angst vor
infektionen wird auf den meisten
baustellen noch nicht wieder gearbeitet
wir haben weiter keine einnahmen und
können nicht mal unsere schulden mit
leichen
sie bleiben meist unter sich
doch das risiko sich anzustecken bleibt
eine alternative aber haben sie nicht
ganz einfach ich kann es mir finanziell
nicht leisten sich zu arbeiten
drei monate lang zu hause zu bleiben das
wäre unmöglich nicht nur für mich auch
für die anderen die in unserem gewerbe
sind ohne die unterstützung der
regierung ist das unmöglich auf große
hilfsprogramme der regierung in teheran
aber brauchen sie nicht zu hoffen
die hat selbst kein geld der wochenmarkt
macht weniger umsatz weil die touristen
fehlen
sie sind es zwar gewohnt sich irgendwie
durchzuschlagen das corona virus aber
belastet sie zusätzlich mein mann war
vorher schon arbeitslos wir sitzen zu
hause rum und keiner kümmert sich um uns
wir haben von denen nicht mal ein paar
plastikhandschuhe bekommen auf großen
plakaten dank die regierung den ärzten
und krankenpflegern und hebt die
beschränkungen schritt für schritt
wieder auf bald sollen auch die heiligen
stätten und die moscheen wieder öffnen
die rollläden gehen wieder hoch das
leben kehrt zurück in die hauptstadt
sogar die einkaufszentren sind wieder
geöffnet
bislang angeblich noch ohne auswirkungen
auf die infektionszahlen zahlen denn das
volk sowieso nicht vertraut aber die
menschen haben kaum eine andere wahl
sie haben angst um ihre gesundheit aber
auch um ihre wirtschaftliche existenz
stillstand kann sich das iranische volk
nicht leisten ein volk das seit vielen
jahren nur krisen kennt